the u.s was represented by secretary of
state anthony blinken
in his first direct albeit virtual talks
with the iraqi government
foreign minister foreign hussein headed
the iraqi delegation
emphasizing the high-level nature of the
discussions
and his national security advisor made
clear that the us military presence in
iraq
was top of the agenda
the two sides agreed that there will be
no american military bases in iraq
and therefore there will be no foreign
bases this is what was agreed upon today
at the end of the third round of the
strategic dialogue
relations between the two countries have
been fraught
particularly following the us airstrike
in january last year
that killed top iranian general qasim
solomoni
and an iraqi militia leader near baghdad
airport
in the wake of the attack iraqi
lawmakers passed a non-binding
resolution
on u.s led coalition forces leaving the
country
and though relations have improved
slightly after mustafa al-khadimi took
over as prime minister
some parties like the iran-backed fatah
bloc
continued to demand u.s withdrawal
the calls further fueled after president
biden ordered an air strike
on a militia base on the syrian side of
the iraqi border
in january u.s soldiers and contractors
are the target of regular attacks by
militia groups
and the biden administration says it
will not hesitate to respond
if the iraqi government doesn't
despite all these factors the us does
not envisage an
imminent withdrawal a pentagon spokesman
making clear
that though this is a subject of ongoing
discussion
there is no timeline
the mission's still valid the invitation
by the iraqi government is still in
place and we're continuing as we have
been even before today's talks
to talk with the iraqi government about
what that what that mission and that
footprint is supposed to look like
all u.s troops were withdrawn from iraq
by december 2011.
president obama ordered their return
three years later
to assist iraqi forces in their battle
against isil
some two and a half thousand troops
still remain
in what the pentagon says is
increasingly
a training capacity following the latest
round of talks it appears they too
will leave the question and answered is
when mike hannah al jazeera
washington